so my name is Jason Silva I am the
creator of shots of awe which hopefully
some of you guys have seen haha I am
also the host of brain games on the
National Geographic Channel as well as
the show origins but where does this all
start for me what is the origin story
where it is the inspiration for my work
come from where does the agitation for
my work come from where does the fire in
the belly that compels me to so
forcefully express myself all the time
come from and the truth of the matter is
it comes from existential angst yeah it
comes from just a feeling of sometimes
paralyzing fear occasional dread wanting
to make sense of things wondering what
it's all about wondering why we're here
wondering what our purpose is in the
cosmos it comes from all of these things
that and a thousand other neurotic
obsessions I assure you I remember
reading a book by Ernest Becker Pulitzer
Prize winning book from 1974 called the
denial of death and just to give you a
pop-culture reference for that book in
the movie Annie Hall it is the book that
Woody Allen makes reference to in the
bookstore when he wants to buy this book
for her and he says you have to read
this book it describes my view of the
human condition this book changed my
life this book basically made this case
about the human condition it distilled
the human conundrum it explained the
mystery of our being in the mystery of
our angst it was extremely well
articulated in a documentary about
Ernest Becker's work called flight from
death the quest for immortality and the
documentary began like the
and it really says it all to have
emerged from nothing to have a name
consciousness of self deep inner feeling
an excruciating inner yearning for life
and self-expression and with all of this
yet to die human beings find themselves
in quite the predicament right we have
the mental capacity to ponder the
infinite seemingly capable of anything
yet were housed in these heart pumping
breath gasping decaying bodies right
simultaneously gods and worms human
beings exist at the interplay between
the finite and the infinite the
philosopher Tolstoy said man cannot live
if he doesn't find a way to bridge the
finite with the infinite college
professor named Sheldon Solomon also
featured in there Ernest Becker
documentary said the explicit awareness
that you're a breathing piece of
defecating meat destined to die and
ultimately no more significant than the
lizard or a potato is not especially
uplifting I mean I memorize that line
because I was like holy that sums
it up people ask me why I have this
recall for quotes that resonate it's
because when something explains when a
quote is it explains something that I
have felt more viscerally and artfully
than I could have ever done it I have to
retain that quote I have to own that
line that line is now part of who I am
that line that quote that idea now
explains how I see the world and there
is reassurance in finding somebody who
sees things the way that you do it makes
you feel less alone
it doesn't absolve us of our aunt
and the mortal coil but at least it
makes us feel like we're all in it
together others understand there is
consensus that we are in a unique
position we've committed no crime yet we
are afflicted with a death sentence now
I've had my share of panic attacks in my
life occasionally from smoking too much
pot but the point being I've entertained
the abyss I lost sleep thinking about
the end I worry about people I love
getting older I worry about my parents
one day succumbing to mortality and I am
NOT at peace with this idea I do not
ascribe to any philosophy that accepts
death in fact as Alan Harrington
beautifully wrote in the immortal list
any philosophy that accepts death must
itself be considered dead it's questions
meaningless its consolations worn out
now I hope that eventually I discover
some philosophy that absolves me from
this angst but at the moment I love so
intensely I feel so deeply and I am so
attached to the people in my life that I
love I am so attached to having
self-awareness to probing the mysteries
of being I am in the words of Carl Sagan
a wonder junkie and I just refuse to
surrender that capacity to the forces of
entropy aging and death
that's where it starts for me this
desire for self-expression
according to Ernest Becker is one of the
three solutions to the problem of death
and I'm sorry to start the night with
this existential bummer which by the way
is the most popular video I've ever done
but the existential bummer is that we
are uniquely aware right and so Ernest
Becker Maps
three ways in which human beings have
dealt with the unique awareness of our
mortality we are the only being in the
animal kingdom that can contemplate its
own death so it's not just that we're
running away from immediate predators
but that even if everything's awesome we
lose sleep over the fact that one day we
will die one day the Sun will eclipse
and burn the earth one day it's all
gonna end that's a bummer and a half as
far as I'm concerned so how do human
beings do this right we construct these
symbolic systems and we invest ourselves
in these systems we create virtual
realities and we invest ourselves in
these virtual realities or even more
appropriately these real virtuality z--
because once you commit to these they
become real they become the lenses
through which you see the world and
these reality tunnels these cultural
operating systems into our lives with
maps of meaning they give us a
directionality they show the way right
the first and most impactful solution to
the death problem was the virtual
reality known as religion it absolves us
of our fear because guess what you'll
live forever in the kingdom of God don't
worry about this mortality thing you're
set sounds great sounds amazing however
if you're requesting questioning mind it
keeps asking questions of your rabbi or
your priest eventually you get kicked
out of Sunday school or whatever it may
be and then you turn to maybe science or
whatever the point is our increasingly
secular society finds no alleviation of
our ills and religion anymore so the
first solution to the problem of death
for many no longer works the second
solution to the problem of death is
romantic love the deification of the
other she's like the wind
she's my salvation she is the Sun it is
every
song that's ever been written it is
every a romantic movie we've ever
watched I can tell you every girl I've
ever been in love with fits the
archetype from some goddess of cinema
that I had a crush on growing up the
iconography of our youth the images the
album covers these things become our
maps of meaning when I find the one she
will save me from it all
by deifying by putting lovers on
pedestals turning them into gods we have
a chance of being saved by rubbing up
against them in a moment of Accession
but guess what as much as I continue to
be a romantic Ernest Becker reminds us
soberly no relationship can bear the
burden of godhood ultimately our gods
will reveal their clay feet ouch the
cracks in our gods and goddesses are
reflections that remind us of our own
cracks and it's like what now the third
solution to the problem of death perhaps
the most interesting one the creative
solution to the problem of death right
we talked about the religious solution
we talked about the romantic solution
the next one is the creative solution to
the problem of death what can we build
what can we do what can we create
together to overcome to transcend to
redefine our boundaries to expand the
perimeters of the possible to overcome
our limits to put things together in a
certain way in which things become
transcendent the creative solution to
the problem of death is our artistry our
poetry our instruments our music our
songs our films our rocket ships and
satellites and iPhones miracles of
Engineering in which we engender our own
divinity increasingly and forcefully my
passion for technology
comes from an abiding belief that
technology is the embodiment of human
creativity in the world
technology is the literalization
of human imagination in the world
technology becomes the human mind turned
inside out and as Kevin Kelly from Wired
magazine said imagine how impoverished
the world would be if we didn't invent
the technology of the oil painting in
time for van gogh or the technology of
the musical instrument in time for
Beethoven and Mozart where the
technology of the written word in time
for Shakespeare these tools and
technologies become conduits for new
forms of human creativity new forms of
human flourishing that for a moment at
least allow us to transcend our
animality and become our triumph over
death this is my abiding belief in human
creativity the most metaphysical of
metaphysical qualities perhaps and
increasingly allowing us to modify our
own evolution I give a lot of lectures
around the world about disruptive
technologies people in a Silicon Valley
are getting wet with the idea of the
singularity billionaires can taste
technologically mediated immortality
this stuff is within our grasp we don't
just build rocket ships that take us to
other planets we don't just build cell
phones in which we warp space and time
in a form of technologically mediated
telepathy where minds can communicate
with each other across oceans of sky
we don't just do this these exponential
technologies which have shrunk
supercomputers the size of buildings
into devices in our pockets
are now spilling over into bio
technology which means mastering the
information processes of our biology
because it turns out that we are made of
code that bio biology is language is is
software that writes its own hardware we
are made of language we are linguistic
all the way down we are alphabetic
beings and now we're learning to reap
Oh Graham that language our existential
angst our refusal to accept our fate is
now giving us the tools to rewrite the
very code of life to change the terms we
didn't sign up for will create new
software apps for biology and say this
cancer thinks screw that human
beings don't die of illness anymore this
aging thing that here's another
thousand years to learn explore and
probe the galaxy the speed at which we
can sequence our genes today is going
three times faster than these
exponential growth curves that they love
talking about in Silicon Valley in other
words the forty years that it took to
take a supercomputer to shrink down from
half a building to a phone in your
pocket right the exponential growth
curve is happening in biotech gene
sequencing is growing three times faster
than Moore's Law this is the kind of
progress this feels like an
inevitability it feels like creativity
and technology in a symbiotic way have a
directionality there seems to be a
teleological move towards greater
complexity and organization Kevin Kelly
from Wired magazine calls technology the
Technium calls it the seventh kingdom of
life he says it's alive he says it has a
wants and it has needs and it's pulling
towards greater forms of novelty and
gendering more possibilities more
creativity more imagination increasing
our options Eric Davis says when
everything becomes linked with
everything else matter becomes mind
we're seeing the rise of artificial
intelligence
non-biological Minds in marriage with us
increasing intelligence beyond its
biological limitations so now we are a
hybrid now we are a cyborg of biological
and non-biological intelligence in fact
there's a whole school of cognitive
philosophers namely David Chalmers and
Clark that say that we have a skin back
bias in assuming that we are nature and
technology is not that in fact
technology is a second skin technology
is our scaffolding and that the mind
that intelligence exists instead in the
feedback loops between brains tools and
environment so we are already part
something else part biology and part
something else again we start with the
human condition we start with the fire
in the belly
we start with existential dread we start
with what the do we do with
ourselves right first we pray then we
worship I lovers finally we get really
creative and we surprise ourselves and
realizing we contain wonders that we and
we are capable of achieving the
impossible Steven Johnson in his book
where good ideas come from a natural
history of innovation talks about the
adjacent possible the adjacent possible
is a shadow from the future that hovers
over the present and provides a map of
all the ways in which the present can
reinvent itself how do we tap into that
adjacent possible lot to think about so
I want to show you a video to set up our
initial condition as we walk through
some of my work in some of the ways in
which I've dealt with this situation
please show the first video
all is temporary even our greatest
ecstasy's are tinged by a bit of
darkness this moment will pass this
moment will end
I may have lost her I may have lost this
moment but now I have this piece of
content that I can always go back to to
remind me of the intensity of that I
will not just like forget this I will
not forget you
[Music]
for me a life well-lived is a life that
is not about victories or losses but
about a continuous process of growth a
continuous process of adventure
curiosity and awe
one in which you don't go quietly into
that good night at the end of the race
but instead you rage and rage and rage
against the dying of the light
as Alan Harrington said we must never
forget we are cosmic revolutionaries not
Stooges conscripted to advance a natural
order that kills everyone
having invented the gods
we can turn into them